hello guys and welcome back to
jaegerists
in today's video we will be going
through the story of peak finger leave a
like on this video and subscribe to our
channel if you want to see more content
like this
pique grew up in the liberio internment
zone and lost her mother early on in
childhood seeing that her father had
gotten sick and would not survive long
without proper medical care pique joined
the warrior program as soon as she was
eligible after performing well enough to
be selected to inherit one of the
marlian titans pique was able to secure
her father the treatment he needed
despite this pique recognized that her
father now had a sadness in his eyes
after learning that she would only live
for 13 more years due to the curse of
emir
after peak inherited the powers of the
kart titan
she was kept in marley along with zeke
yeager as a deterrent to enemy nations
while the other warriors are sent to
take part in the paradise island
operation
five years into the mission to reclaim
the founding titan peak journeys to
paradise island with zeke yeager and a
contingent of marley and soldiers using
her cart titan to carry supplies for
them she is present as zeke and the
soldiers transform the inhabitants of a
small village into titans
pique is one of the warriors brought by
zeke to engage the survey corps in
shiganshinon district during the night
before the soldier's arrival pique keeps
watch for their movement in the desolate
regions of walmaria south of trost
district upon seeing the advancing
soldiers she returns to the ruins of
shiganchanon and informs zeke reiner and
bertholdt of their approach
pique remains with zeke's beast titan
during the ensuing battle serving as a
cargo mule of sorts for the warriors
various supplies pique also assists zeke
by supplying him with rocks to crush and
throw at the soldiers berthold is kept
hidden in a barrel atop peaks back as a
plan b against the survey corps and upon
reiner's defeat at the hands of the
soldier's thunder spears
beritholt is removed from her titan's
back and thrown by the beast titan into
the city the soldiers choose to engage
in a suicidal charge against the beast
titan in order to buy time for captain
levi to move in for a counter attack
as zeke decimates them he is quickly
caught off guard and defeated by levi
pique comes to his rescue and carries
his dismembered human form away
zeke guides peek into shiganshilan to
rescue reiner and bertholdt only to find
berthold incapacitated and captured by
aaron yeager zeke attempts to talk aaron
down but the arrival of levi forces the
two to abandon bertholdt searching
elsewhere in the district the kart titan
rescues reiner from capture before
climbing atop walmarea where the
warriors are safe
after returning to marley pique is among
those that send off the initial survey
ship sent to paradise island four years
later pique is present at the battle of
fort slava at the climax of the war
between marley and the mid-east allied
forces
while colt suggests that she should
engage in combat with the fort's
defenses commander theo mcgoth denied
the suggestion due to the presence of
anti-titan artillery which could kill
any titan with a single round
once the artillery is destroyed pique
enters the battlefield with her kart
titan fully armored and equipped with
four manned machine guns and begins to
assault the bunkers of the mid-east
allied forces alongside porco galliard's
jaw titan after the battle peak joins
galliard and reiner braun recovering
from his injuries received in the battle
as a result of spending two consecutive
months in her titan form
pique has been forced to walk with a
crutch while reiner leaves pique stays
behind to rest by galliard
she later joins the rest of the marlin
military on the train returning to their
home town seated among the other
warriors when the train reaches the
station pique gets off the train and
walks with the rest of the warriors
towards liberio when inside she is
happily greeted by her father pique is
later seen at the warrior headquarters
spotted by galliard walking on all fours
like her titan as she believes it to be
more natural
galliard irritated tells her to walk on
two feet like a normal human throughout
the meeting between the warriors peek is
observed sitting on a couch and furthers
zeke jaeger's argument that the tiber
family is necessary to help the warriors
regain the founding titan pique later
attends a military meeting discussing
the logistics of an assault on paradise
island she stays silent until the
conclusion of this meeting when she goes
outside to join her fellow warriors on a
balcony pique expresses her discontent
with the senior military officers
finding them foolish for their
lackluster past plans and wonders about
the future of the audience some time
before the beginning of willie tiber's
speech at the liberio festival pique and
the other warriors are ordered to take
their seats as ambassadors of marley
after they are seated a marlin soldier
informs the warriors that mcgoth wants
to see them along the way the soldier
dismisses zeke causing pique to become
suspicious she comments that the soldier
feels familiar but becomes distracted
when she sees the panzer unit that
operates the artillery her cart titan
carries in battle pique eagerly goes
over and discreetly informs them about
her suspicions regarding the soldier
escorting them the soldier leads peak
and galliard to an empty building and
she realizes that they have been led
into a trap as the soldier cuts a nearby
rope it opens a trapdoor beneath her and
a galleyard peak and galliard fall into
a warrior confinement area fracturing
their bones in the process they observe
the lack of space to transform so decide
to wait with the supplies provided
galliard questions the identity and
intentions of the soldier who trapped
them peek states that she is not sure
but she remembers the soldier from
somewhere before later the two begin to
feel tremors from outside peak deduces
that the tremors are from titans
fighting outside and that this would be
the reason they were trapped while
discussing a means of escape her panzer
unit comes to the warriors rescue
she explains to galliard that she took
safety measures because of their
suspicious escort the soldiers let down
a rope and help the warriors climb out
of the pit
peak's unit informs them about the
attack titan's sudden appearance and how
the warhammer titan is currently
engaging it in battle peak orders her
unit to prepare her titan's armor and
galliard prepares to go and join the
battle
before he leaves pig suggests that he
observed the situation for a while so
they can better understand the enemy
attacking them they are then shocked to
see a group of soldiers fly over them
using vertical maneuvering equipment
as the others stare in awe peak recalls
seeing the same technology during her
brief time on paradise island
though it takes some time pique has her
panzer unit equip her titan with the
heavy machine gun armament believing
that it would be perfect against the
vertical maneuvering equipment when she
arrives at the battlefield
she and the panzer unit surprise the
survey corps with an artillery barrage
killing several soldiers and saving
galliard from death she perches on top
of a building and joins the rest of the
titans of marley in a showdown against
the survey corps peak provides cover for
zeke as two soldiers try to approach him
with thunderspears but nearly gets
killed by one only for galliard to save
her after thanking him pique is told to
watch out for the ackerman lurking
nearby she tells galliard that what they
need to do is protect zeke
pique then sees the explosion caused by
the transformation of the colossus titan
at the edge of the city realizing that
bertholdt hoover was killed and had his
titan ability stolen by the enemy after
galliard charges towards aaron yeager
pique tries calling him back but to no
avail she then groups up with zeke to
attack the survey corps but is surprised
to see zeke fall
she and her panzer unit become the focus
of the survey corps and one of her
gunners is shot in the head
she charges towards the soldier who
killed him but jean kirsten intercepts
her and launches a thunder spirit peak
it bounces off her titan's helmet and
into one of the eye slots where it
detonates the rest of peak's gunners are
killed by a barrage of thunderspheres
which also severely damages her titan
pique stumbles off the roof of the
building and falls right in front of
falco grease gabby braun and mcgoth
beaten and injured pique is momentarily
saved by the sudden intervention of
falco who shields her from jean when
jean fires his thunder spear pique
releases a small burst of steam and he
misses his shot this gives falco and
gabby enough time to get peek away from
the battle while mcgoth and his soldiers
cover their escape by the time they get
peaked to safety she later stirs as the
warrior candidates call out for reiner
pique realizes that the soldier who had
trapped her in galliard was aboard the
first survey ship sent to paradis and
presumed to have perished after it
failed to report in believing the
soldier to be a follower of zeke pique
reports to mcgoth her suspicions after
the battle pique recovers in a room
together with reiner braun and porco
galliard
during an emergency meeting theo mcgoth
explains peak's theory that zeke yeager
has been planning his raid with a team
of co-conspirators from inside the
marlin military magoth then tells the
others they will wait for the global
alliance to assemble before reiner
declares that they should launch a
surprise attack against paradis island
now
pique is sent along with galliard ahead
of the other marley forces to paradise
island to seek out aaron as she reads a
newspaper she manages to overhear a few
citizens bitterly comment about the
recent actions of the survey corps she
then infiltrates the ranks of the
jageris within shiganshinan when aaron
jaeger enters gabby braun's prison cell
to convince her to cooperate pique
surprises him by stabbing an
accompanying guard in the throat
pointing her firearm at aaron pique
tells gabby to be silent while
confirming her target's identity
threatening to kill aaron if he does not
comply pique ultimately backs down due
to her mission of taking aaron in alive
after telling aaron that she wishes to
free the audience just like him gabby
immediately accuses her of being a
traitor like zeke
pique tells gabby that despite the heads
of the military telling them otherwise
the warriors and their families are not
honorary marlians and will always be
seen as lower class citizens when gabby
protests pique reminds her that with the
advancements in technology marley will
no longer rely solely on titans for
warfare and all the aldians honorary or
not will be killed due to not being
needed anymore
aaron asks her to prove herself and
pique volunteers to show him where the
other infiltrators are located after
being handcuffed to gabby and taken to
the roof
pique asks aaron if this means they are
on the same side aaron merely responds
that pique should not try anything due
to potentially killing gabby if she
tries to transform they meet yelena at
the roof pique whimsically recalls her
treachery in liberio mentioning that
yelena looks nice with the fake goatee
when pressured to reveal her comrades
peek grips gabby's hand and smiles at
her she then turns and points at aaron
just then galliard's jaw titan bursts
through and takes aaron and the
jaegerist by surprise
as this happens pete grabs gabby and
dives out of the way as the jaw titan
shields them from the blast of aaron
transforming pique tells gabby that
while she does want to free the aldians
she trusts her comrades to help with the
liberation efforts
after getting away peek calls out to
galliard galliard spots that peek and
gabby are shackled together and cuts off
her lower arms so that she can transform
peak falls off the roof and transforms
having gabby climb into her titan's
mouth and the two flee
they meet up with magoth and his
soldiers and pique informs them of the
number of paradise's forces and that
zeke has not yet arrived in the district
pique and magoth are puzzled by the fact
that aaron has not yet activated the
founder but gabby's revelation that zeke
stated that paradise has now a titan of
royal blood leads them to theorize that
zeke is that titan and that aaron needs
to be in contact with him to activate
the founder pique declares that they
cannot allow aaron and zeke to come into
contact with each other and begins to
climb wall maria with magoth
upon reaching the top of the wall magoth
mans the cannon and shoots aaron's titan
in the head temporarily disabling him
they fire another shot at aaron to
incapacitate him further but before they
can fire anymore they are interrupted by
zeke's arrival after zeke annihilates
the marlian airships he takes aim at
peak and she is barely able to avoid a
barrage of stones clinging to the side
of the wall she advises mcgoff to not
fight zeke head on but he refuses just
then a small group of jaegers arrive and
begins to target them forcing peak to
retreat to trick her pursuers pique
exits her titan form and hides in the
steam of her titan's decaying body
making it look as though she has been
killed the jaegerists are then fired
upon by marley and soldiers from the
cart titans carcass while mcgoth subtly
angles the artillery to get a clear shot
at zeke afterwards magoth lands a direct
hit on zeke's beast titan knocking him
off the wall
as mcgoff fires another shot into the
head of aaron's titan both he and peak
come under attack from flock forster and
the jaegerists they managed to fend off
their attackers and resume firing upon
aaron and zeke however the artillery
cannon is then destroyed by the efforts
of both armin alert and mikasa ackerman
with no artillery to continue shooting
at aaron and zeke's titan forms pique is
forced to engage her two assailants
targeting them both
pete proclaims it is over and charges
towards mikasa
however before she can aaron makes
contact with zeke to start the rumbling
and pique grips the wall as it begins to
disintegrate beneath her like all
subjects of emir pique is then able to
suddenly hear aaron's voice and his
declaration to protect the people of
paradise island
pique and macgoth retreat from
shiganshanan and observe marley's
airships leaving the island
as pique and mcguff discuss what to do
next they are caught off guard by an
approaching soldier
peak prepares to attack but the soldier
insists that they and their companion
are heartless pique and mcgoth later
agree to join forces with hange and levi
in order to stop aaron the group
contacts jean kirsten and mikasa and
coordinates a plan for peak to rescue
them along with anyon kapon and yelena
using her titan form
pique abducts jean on yonkopon and
yelena and takes them back to haines
levi and magoth
that night as the combined forces of
marley and paradise are eating together
magoth attempts to ask yelena where
aaron intends to attack first
the survey court tried to remind her
that her homeland which she joined the
volunteers to save from marley will be
destroyed by aaron and pique shocks them
all by revealing that she has discovered
that yelena is in fact marlian
the following day pique is sent to scout
paradise's docks to see if it will be
safe for the group to follow aaron pique
returns from her mission to reveal that
the jaegers have occupied the docks in
anticipation of retaliation against
aaron
while her allies engage the jaegerists
pique uses her titan form to transport
the members of the group who are unable
to fight
pique tries to advise falco greece
against joining the battle but the youth
chooses to ignore her peak leaves the
non-combatants on a boat in the harbor
and engages the jaegerists herself she
is joined by falco and the two quickly
wipe out the remaining gagarists as the
group prepares to leave falco begins
losing control of his titan form and
pique attempts to talk him down talking
proves futile and falco attacks peak
forcing her to subdue him while macguth
cuts him out of its titan the ordeal
leaves pique badly injured and she has
to be carried onto the boat by hange
as they escape from the harbor a
grieving peak embraces gappy as they
witness general mcgoth sacrifice himself
by blowing up a marlin cruiser on the
dock
after arriving in odaho peak attempts to
comfort falco after informing him of
magoth's death and liberio's destruction
afterwards hearing that levi is planning
to interrogate yelena pique volunteers
to join
after getting elena to reveal aaron's
next destination
pique informs kiyomi that she intends to
lock gabby and falco in their room on
the ship so that they cannot board the
flying boat kiyomi agrees to watch over
the children in her stead after saying
goodbye to annie who intends to stay
behind pique and reiner join the survey
corps hainge gives them the opportunity
to stay behind but the two insist that
they are continuing until the end
preparations for departure are
interrupted by flock who damages the
boat's fuel tank necessitating time for
repairs to be done as aaron's titans
arrive in odaha hange stays behind to
hold them off while peek and the others
board the boat and depart
as the flying boat reaches aaron it
comes under fire from the beast titan as
the rest of the group jump from the boat
peak grabs the explosives and drags them
out of the boat with her transforming
mid air
pique transports the explosive in her
titan's mouth while her comrades engage
the beast's titan they make quick work
of the beast but zeke is not found in
its nape
peak and the group retreat to give armin
room to transform and uncover zeke's
location with the blast but he is
overtaken by an army of titans which
begins generating atop aaron's titan
levi devises a plan to save him but
pique reveals that the titans they are
facing are former inheritors of the nine
titans realizing that aaron can generate
an infinite number of titans pique tries
to rush to his nape on her own and use
the explosives to kill him she manages
to set the explosives around his nape
but before she can set them off her
titan gets impaled by the younger sister
of willy's warhammer titan exiting her
titan pique quickly transforms again and
kills the warhammer titan she uses her
titan to kill nearby titan's attacking
gene before ejecting from her titan as
it is torn apart transforming once more
in mid-air pique explains to gene that
her cart titan's endurance effectively
allows her to transform as many times as
she wants jean attempts to reach the
explosives peak left at erin's nape but
is cut off by more titans and pique
sullenly admits that even her abilities
are not enough to clear a path to the
explosives peak's regeneration abilities
reach their limit and leave her unable
to heal her injury requiring jane to
return and save her jean attempts to
retreat to reiner with her but the two
find that reiner himself has been
overwhelmed pique and jean are nearly
killed but they are saved by the
intervention of porco and marcel
galliard's jaw titans pique transforms
again and joins her resurrected comrades
and holding off the remaining hostile
titans while gene finally reaches
aaron's nape and destroys it falco's
flying jaw titan arrives to retrieve the
group and pete convinces gene to leave
reiner behind to ensure aaron does not
regenerate before armin transforms
the group returns to fort salta where
pique is able to reunite with her father
their reunion is short-lived however
when it is revealed that aaron and the
source of all living matter both
survived armin's transformation the
source begins emitting smoke at the base
of fort salta and pique is horrified to
learn from levi that the smoke is going
to turn the elden's present into pure
titans grief stricken
peak joins mikasa and levi aboard falco
as her father and companions are
transformed pique is given the task of
helping reiner prevent the source from
returning to aaron while mikasa and levi
engage erin directly with armin she
attacks the source directly but is
quickly overwhelmed by the army of pure
titans along with reiner and annie
following aaron's death the power of the
titans is eliminated from the world and
all of the eldians returned to their
human forms as her audience all begin to
recover memories of aaron which he
temporarily erased
pique jokingly laments that she would
have liked to speak with him as well
as the aldians regroup the surviving
marlian soldiers from salta come out to
confront them
the marlians threaten to kill them if
they cannot prove that they are no
longer titans and only armin is able to
talk them down in the three years
following aaron's death the survivors of
the battle of heaven and earth at fort
salta are made peace ambassadors between
the remnants of the outside world and
paradise
as the ambassadors sailed to paradise to
begin peace talks in the year 857
annie points out that the odds of them
successfully negotiating with paradise
are low
armin however
is confident that the sight of the
warriors and the survey corps
former enemies working together will be
enough to get the alliance of paradis to
listen
thank you so much for watching this
video
it really means a lot to us
we will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos